[Music]
hello everyone
in the previous lecture we were
discussing uh
the complementary energy and uh that
concept of the complementary energy will
pave the way
uh for something extremely important
uh in our discussions of energy methods
uh called the castigliano's theorem
and it is this classical theorem whose
application will enable us
to solve a number of very useful
engineering problems
now as a first step towards uh towards
that useful theorem
we are first going to discuss this
rather long looking
name of the theorem uh generalization of
castigliano's theorem of least
work now because of whatever historical
reasons it has been named as such
but the uh but the real point here is
that
uh this theorem that we are going to
discuss uh
uh it doesn't really
directly involve any work uh nor does it
deal
and deal with anything least or minimum
rather what it actually deals with
is a an extremization
of something which is referred to as the
modified form of
the complementary energy okay so we had
discussed about the complementary energy
in the previous lecture
uh today we are going to discuss the
modified form of the complementary and
you are going to define that
and then you will see that this theorem
it will deal with
uh with a certain version or certain use
of that
modified uh complementary energy
so what what is this theorem all about
okay so i'm not going to write
the grand formal statement of this
theorem that is very much present in our
lecture notes you can refer to that
later on
uh let's discuss this again in a very
utilitarian fashion
okay so consider as always we do
a general three-dimensional body
okay something like this uh maybe i use
a different color for this
we considered a general
three-dimensional body like this
and uh you consider various
uh you consider a very general way of
the boundary conditions which are set
here so over a part of this surface
of this body so if the entire surface is
denoted by
s let us say that over a part of the
surface may be
from here to here okay maybe i use a
different color also for that
maybe from here to here all over this
that is given by s1
part of the surface and over here
the traction is specified okay and over
the rest of it
we use a different color for that over
the rest of it
let's say that it is s2
it is the displacements which are
specified okay so over this s1
part of the boundary traction suspensive
and over the rest of it
we have displacements specified
now what this theorem okay you may call
this
if you want the modified complementary
energy theorem if you like
so what this theorem is stating is that
uh of all the stress states that may be
possible
in response to this kind of attraction
and displacement
boundary conditions the
actual stress state of stress that will
be present
in this body that will correspond
to a
an extremum of something called the
modified complementary energy
okay so i repeat of all the stress
states that are possible
uh which satisfy the mechanical
equilibrium equations and the boundary
conditions everything
okay so the actual state of stress that
will be possible over the body
that will correspond that that that the
real answer will correspond
to an extremum okay
mind you it is not the minimum or the
maximum it is the extrema
of the modified complementary energy
so in very very short
what this theorem is basically telling
us is that the stress state
will just correspond to this
where this capital psi
the first variation of this capital psi
this capital psi
uh this capital psi
it corresponds uh it is the modified
complementary energy
and i'll define this in a in just a
moment
so it is defined
as u dash
which as we have mentioned in the
previous lecture
this u dash is the complementary energy
minus
integration of u i e i
e s so this is a surface integral
but very importantly please note that
this is the surface integral
over just the s2 okay it is not over the
entire surface of the body
but it is over s2 and we'll see how it
how it comes about
okay so so this is a theorem we will
formally say that we are going to
go about with a proof of this theorem
but uh
but before we can actually launch into
the proof there are a couple of things
which you should note okay so before
long before going into the proof
a couple of things to note
okay so the first thing to note
is that because the body will be in
equilibrium
we know for a fact that our stress
equilibrium equations
will hold true so we have this thing
now we take the first variation of this
and see what that gives us okay so if we
take the first variation of this
we'll put the variation symbol here and
then
we can take that inside the partial
derivative to obtain
this now please note that because
the bound and because the body forces on
the body
the the body forces they are specified
there will be no variation on this
okay so this is a rather subtle concept
but this is something which we are going
to utilize
uh a few more times down the line so
please
take note of it so whenever something is
actually given to us
as part of the problem statement
and if you want to take the variation of
that that is
0 because as part of the proof
we do not know a priory what the value
of the stress will be
that is in that sense we are seeking the
variation of it
and trying to arrive at the correct
answer so it is very much possible to
consider the variations of the stresses
but it doesn't make any sense to carry
out the variation of something
which we know okay because that is a a
nice
a constant value given to us so the
first variation of this entire term
that is going to be zero okay so the
first
variation of this stress equilibrium
equation uh from that we
obtained this the next thing okay so
this is the first thing before the proof
the second thing that we want to
uh note uh is directly from the
definition
of the complementary energy more
specifically the complementary
energy density okay so this u
dash naught as we have seen in the
earlier lecture
in the previous lecture actually that
was given by this in terms of the
of the strain energy of u naught plus
we had this sigma p q epsilon p q
you can write this as sigma i j epsilon
i t doesn't make any difference
if you take the first variation of this
what we obtain is
this thing plus this
where we have just taken this part by
part
okay and
please note that we have uh we have
already seen
that this thing this delta u naught uh
that is nothing but minus
sigma eq
delta epsilon pq
so if you get you can refer to the
previous notes to obtain this
note this expression okay so
as you can see this first term is going
to cancel
with this third term
ultimately what we have for the first
variation of the uh
the complementary energy density is just
this delta sigma pq
epsilon pq okay we could have written
all of this
in terms of i j but uh doesn't make any
difference
all right so with this thing uh in our
hand we can now go on
to the actual proof so
uh what we'll do is uh
we will because
you see we have to ultimately prove that
delta psi
this delta capital psi is equal to 0 we
are going to start with this part
delta u dash okay and if we can show
that delta u dash is equal to
the delta of this thing then our job
will be basically done because then we
can just transpose this thing to the
left hand side and we can
see that that entire thing is this psi
and then we can say the delta psi is
equal to zero this is our plan
okay we are going to uh we are going to
try to show
that delta u dash is equal to the delta
of this
thing that's the plan okay so
let me go to the next slide
delta u dash if we proceed step by step
this will be so this is basically the u
dash is the complementary energy and we
write that in terms
of the uh of the
complementary energy density okay i have
skipped a step here because
uh i mean you understand that this delta
should have been
outside and then i take that inside so
i've skipped a step here but you
understand that
okay now just in the previous slide we
have
uh shown uh before launching into the
proof two things one of which
was an expression for this delta u
naught dash
you can just take a quick glance back
here so this delta u naught dash
is delta sigma p q epsilon p q so i'll
write
instead of this p q i'll write this in
terms of
i j okay so
let's get back
so this is uh
epsilon i j i write the epsilon first
and then this
radiation term
this is exactly the same thing that we
had written in the previous page
all right now from our knowledge of the
strain displacement relations
we can write this epsilon i j as half
del ui del x j
plus del u j del x
i all of you know this we have done this
so many times earlier
in our course on applied elasticity
now very quickly
you note that
this thing can be written
as this
plus half l u j del x i
so this is first we have the u and then
the j and now here we have the j and the
i
but what we are going to do here when
you multiply this thing with this
we are going to change the order of i
and j
in this sigma
okay that can be very well done because
we all know that uh
you all know that sigma i j is equal to
sigma j
i at least for the typical uh cases that
we are concerned with
it can be very very special cases when
that that is not valid but
for this scenario but therefore our
typical scenarios that's perfectly okay
now you see this term uh if you were to
replace the i by
p and the j by k and here
in this term if you replace the j by p
and the i by k
these two terms are exactly the same
okay they are perfectly the same thing
which means that overall i can write
this
as del uy
del xj so this is a little trick that we
play here
all right next up
what we'll do is a little uh a little
algebra
okay we'll use a little algebra
to uh to recast this
in this fashion so
what we wish to do is we wish to take
both this
ui and the sigma ji term the delta sigma
ig
term within the partial derivative
all right now of course you understand
that by writing like this we have
effectively introduced another term
like ui del del xj of delta sigma ij
which the term which was not present in
the previous step so that has to be
subtracted out in order for this
equality to hold
we'll do exactly that
we subtract out the term which we have
artificially introduced
while writing like this
all right now you note uh
we're in a very nice situation because
in the previous slide when we
when we were talking about those couple
of things that we wanted to go into
before
launching into the proof we have already
shown that
for the body to be in equilibrium this
term
that is equal to zero you can take a
quick glue glance back here
we have already shown that del del and
del delta sigma i j
del xj that is equal to zero okay so we
are going to use this thing
so maybe we call this as
uh hash one and this as
hash two so we have utilized uh
back here
uh we've already used hash two
in this step and in uh in
in this step we are going to use the
hash one okay so
this thing is equal to zero using
hash one okay so we go to the uh
we continue with this thing in the next
slide uh
so delta u dash which is just the left
hand side
that is going to be equal to this term
uh
we write that again
del del x j u i
delta sigma i j
dv now you see what we have basically
what you're basically writing here
this is just the uh
so this is just the divergence uh kind
of a situation here
okay so can we not write it
in the next step
sorry about that uh my writing app
kind of misbehaved here uh
so as i was saying uh this
uh we can use it we can use the gauss
divergence theorem here to convert this
volume integral
into a surface integral because we note
that this is like a
this is the divergence basically okay so
this entity within the bracket
here i is repeated so this is basically
just like a vector
and that vector is represented
by the single uh index j and because we
have
this del del x j up so it is like the
del del x j
of some v j where v j is the vector
representing this entire thing
so that is like the divergence of the
vector okay so in the next step
we can use the cause divergence theorem
to convert this into a surface integral
and mind you that this is over the
entire surface
consisting of s1 and s2
okay so this is going to be ui
delta sigma ij
engine
next what we are going to do is
uh we are going to
put this nj within the
within this variational operator and
let me just write that and i'll explain
why that that is possible
okay so uh
what we are basically using here is uh
we are appealing to the small
deformation theory
okay please note that whatever we are
doing here it does not pertain to finite
deformations
finite deformations means the the actual
deformations
they will be non-negligible so what we
are basically saying is that even though
we are considering the body to be
deformable but in reality
the deformability is not so much that
the geometry is changing significantly
so that
if that were the case then the unit
outward normal to the surface
would be varying and then we would not
have been able to treat this
almost like a constant and take this
within this variational operator
so basically what we are saying here is
that
we are using the fact that delta nj is
equal to zero
okay so for all intents and purposes the
geometry doesn't change
that is what we are going we are using
here
all right now what we are going to do uh
is you see this sigma i j n j this is
our
uh very familiar form we can write this
as you know in terms of the
fraction okay because you all know that
sigma i j n j is nothing but t i
using e i
fraction vector is equal to sigma i j
n j all right now it is time to consider
the two parts of the surface
separately remember that initially we
had specified our boundary conditions
this the traction boundary conditions
over s1
and the displacement boundary conditions
over s2
so we considered those two parts of the
of the surface
separately now so first s1
yes plus s2
integration over the s2 sub part of the
surface
the integrand remains the same for now
all right
now you see what is happening this first
integration is over
s1 but over s1
our according to our statement
the the tractions are actually specified
okay so this is a very very important
point to note again so just like before
when before we launched into the proof
we had said that because the boundary
because the body forces are specified to
us
so the first variation of the body force
is going to be 0
so also over the s1 part of the surface
because the tractions are actually given
to us so this
fraction is given to us over s1
so the first variation of the traction
over s1 will be zero
okay so what we are left with
is just this integration
using the fact
that since ti
is specified
over s1
delta ti is equal to 0
over s1
so we proceed uh
we have arrived at this form
where on the right hand side we just
have this integration over the s2 left
and please note that our original
intention
was to show that delta u dash is equal
to
basically so you can go back a couple of
slides
after the statement you see our original
intention before launching it with the
proof was to show that delta u dash
should be equal to delta of this entire
thing and
you see this s2 is very nicely sitting
here so
in terms of
sorry
okay my writing happened misbehaved
sorry about that uh so
in terms of that we are almost there uh
what we have to just do is one little
step
where we realize that now now because we
are considering
the part of the surface s2 there
the it is the displacement boundary
conditions which are specified to us so
the displacements are given to us
which means that again over that delta
ui is equal to 0
okay so we can very well take
this ui within this ti this delta
operator okay so we can write it like
this
using the fact
that ui is specified
over s2 so
delta ui is equal to 0
over s2
and now of course we can take this delta
operator outside the integration
there's nothing stopping us
and write like this and therefore
we can just transpose it to the left
hand side
like this
and then just one more step
and take the delta out
and note that whatever is remaining
within the bracket
that is nothing but the
modified complementary energy
okay so hence
so these are it it seems i mean
i'm sure that if you're a little bit
mathematically inclined the proof will
give you a certain amount of
satisfaction
but then uh it does leave us with the
question that
okay we have done a nice proof so what
i mean how exactly does this help us in
solving problems so by itself this
theorem involving the modified
complementary energy it certainly does
not help us to
solve any problem but it does pave the
way
for uh for the final theorem
which will actually enable us to solve
problems okay
and which we are going to discuss in the
next video thank you very much